I got reminded in the custody as a
police officer serving police officer I
ended up at Pentonville prison about
four or five of them come to my door and
slid the newspaper under the thing with
my picture in it oh
the front yeah well I'm Gonna Get a Kick
this I'm gonna get killed here
[Music]
hello and welcome to this episode of
extraordinary lives a podcast from Lab
Bible today joining us we have Paul Page
Paul welcome thank you if you for anyone
watching or listening could just tell us
who you were yeah my name's Paul page
I'm a former Royal Protection Officer
and previously stationed at Buckingham
Palace
so you've had a fascinating life it's
kind of there's lots of chapters to it
and I guess why don't we start at the
start what was childhood like for you
um well I grew up with my grandparents
um obviously my parents had problems
hence well I was with my grandparents
um they were fairly wealthy so I had a
fairly privileged background
old-fashioned upbringing
um and I was I was put into sports at an
early age
um I didn't feel different not being
with my family obviously I'm an only
child
um I did see my parents but I think my
grandparents
um
they kept me busy and then eventually
you basically the I think the big the
first chapter of your life really is
joining the police yeah so what was it
that made you want to join the police I
really didn't want to join the police at
first okay
um I wanted to join the fiber guide
right but the police weren't recruiting
the Met wasn't recruiting at the time
and neither was London fiber guide so
I'd think um and if I would try sixth
place
um and I managed to get in
and
um it was uh I think I did 20 weeks
training I think it wasn't easy back
then to get in the place I mean I'm
gonna say it's pretty easy now it was up
until recently but
you had to pass a lot of tests
a lot I mean I think I had four
different interviews and then one big
one so it wasn't straightforward I think
they could pick and choose a lot more
then what appealed to you like so I'm
saying it wasn't your first choice but I
thought I wanted to join a parachute
regiment but I was scared of housewife
obviously the fire brigade was another
issue would it would have been another
issue but um I don't know I just I just
um I don't think I could have done with
going away nine months of the year as a
soldier I don't think I had it in me
I'll be honest with you I don't think I
had that sort of uh sort of mentality
where I can lead my family for that
because obviously I was loyal to my
grandparents and they were getting on so
that sort of um that sort of pushed me
away from that idea okay and with the
police were you still because as you say
you come from a quite a disciplined
background yes from the formative years
we still looking for something with that
kind of discipline or was that yeah yeah
but a physical sort of running around
and stuff you know and um
you know what I mean I've been chased by
the place when I was a Youngster not for
any major crimes but I've been a little
[__] at this side you know what I mean
like most kids are
um
and uh
I think what happened when I was in the
ti
a friend of mine who's only 17 18. he
was a soldier as well part-time Soldier
um and he was in a nightclub with his
girlfriend and it was an issue and he
got stabbed to death oh God and um what
happened was they asked us to carry the
coffin in uniform and so they brought a
coffin into the uh ta Center
and I couldn't do it
I didn't have the guts to do it I don't
even go to the funeral I just couldn't
sort of
um get past what had happened and the
shock was too much
and then I saw the you know I looked at
the place and I thought you know what
I'm gonna I'm gonna go for it
um and that environment you are dropped
literally dropped in it from day one
you know it's nothing no matter how much
trying to do nothing can prepare you for
real life but real life within the
police within the police so for the
first few years what were the first few
years like the first year uh I was
assaulted I was nearly shot uh
uh it's got a horribly mutilated dead
body
um so all kinds of different things I
think that year we went and told the
family that I sound a bit unlucky the
only time I've ever done that until some
of the partner had died the son had died
that was horrific
so um yeah there was a lot of things
that happened to me that I was only 20
and I was only still a youngster really
although I've told you I've had this
experience in doing this today numbers
but this was totally different and I
guess like when you say guarding a
horribly mutated dead body like there's
no training that's going to prepare I
mean okay I'm back in them days on what
you would call or what I regard myself
as an old school copper old school
values it means if you're a sort of
police officer you're going to get a
double clamp right and and I'll explain
I'll explain why because back in those
days Society moves on it was acceptable
at certain periods of time it's not
acceptable now if you know what I'm
saying
um and back in those days as police
officers there was only one uh sort of
unit that would protect the police
officer and that's a police officer and
other police officers we didn't regard
the law as particularly protective over
us as individuals
and um I'd seen a number of officers
assorted I'll give you one example I
mean we'll add nicknames back then which
is not politically correct now
um when I joined the job uh I went to
the street juries office and the
sergeant said to me welcome to the art
of Essex this is where you're going to
stay for the rest of your career
probably
um you know so uh he said to Mel can you
make tea he goes I hope you can always
you're gonna be the most unpopular
person on the relief because there's no
there was no sort of oh don't say that
to him you'll know the table and if you
don't like it it's off that's how it was
you don't get to go on a police car
you're going to pan the boat and you're
going to take every job that comes along
not because they're being horrible yeah
because you have to learn your craft you
have to learn your tried
and so they want to see how you get on
and so uh back then a an office say was
a neighborhood beat officer probably few
and far between nowadays
and this officer when it now did wilf
nicknamed him wolf because
he used to go and visit old people's
homes and sit there eating tea and cake
so that's why it's the name wolf and and
bless him he didn't have much about him
so it wasn't he wasn't physically
capable sure but there's there's
different strengths in the place you
don't have to be a you know a macho man
but you know but
so he he's sort of uh Niche was dealing
with Community matters and stuff like
that
a really nice bloke
um all the local youngsters used to 10
of him because he used to ride a bike
and bless him used to tuck his socks in
and all his trads and his socks you know
and back in them days it wasn't really a
good idea
[Music]
um in the areas we were placing so it
went out one night Joe it was uh um
covering with us he was on the car on
his own he went down to a road called
cramerville Street it was about 10 jobs
down there and they baked the absolute
not far nothing it went down because
they were causing the disturbance they
were terrorizing local people
it's gone down there just to let me move
on and they just switched on him I'm
both serving
so basically what we did was we we
rounded them up one by one we
systematically beat the set of them
right
um and the reason for that is if you're
going to touch a police officer so you
better know what's going to happen to
you because next time they could kill up
you Let It Go like a killer police
officer or what they're going to do to
remember the public
that's where a full process was at the
time so were you were you still a junior
officer yeah so you so you're learning
how it works because back then in 92 I
joined the police yeah so I had offices
pre-pace which is placed in criminal
evidence like that came in at 1987.
which was you know it's to stop the SAS
laws and all that so you had to give
reasons for stopping paper and that sort
of thing so a lot of old school offices
and I and I I willingly took on their
their sort of
um where they placed yeah so you wrote
You've rounded so you rounded up this
gang of jobs and as a gang as a group of
police officers you basically beat them
up yeah and did they know why it was
happening yes yeah they knew why it was
happening they were told why it was
happening
um and there was it used to be a thing
called the reception committee and that
basically was uh if you if someone
assaulted a police officer they would
call up on the radio for a reception
committee so everyone would go back to
the police station and when this
individual was brought in he would get
smacked from one end of the custody
office today everybody running on the
PlayStation
um I'm not condoning that but that's
what happened back in those days so
let's get it right now
um I'm not condoning it it's it's wrong
it's illegal etc etc but this is the way
policing was to a certain extent not
everywhere I'm not going to say that
every PlayStation did that or every
police officer did that but it comes
comes back down so we were protecting
the uniform ourselves and back then pull
condom Condon um it was a police
commissioner before I went to the Met
but he said the noble cause corruption
was an issue within many police forces
because police officers were so pissed
off with the way criminals Got Away in
Colts and it made him turn to two types
of criminality in the place one is Ben
for self which is your
um your liaison of criminals in your
supply information for them
um and getting paid for that and give
them information
they're giving you information on stuff
and you're acting upon their information
for their benefit and so on and so forth
and then there's been for the job which
is
sort of uh if if you say I uh an
individual who's been nicked multiple
times for burglary he's at two in the
morning he's got no good reason to bet
you know his bang at it but you just
can't get him on that occasion
so they'll just I've just seen on the
door handle or I've seen pulling at a
window and lift and taking him off the
streets and was that like at that point
in time was that a
would you have thought of that back then
as being corrupt or do you think that
the officers who were no not at the time
that's what I'm saying it's corrupt but
detox or corruption didn't they were the
officers that were sort of doing that
would they have seen it as they were
making a positive
as you call it Safeguard in the
community yeah um and and these
individuals and and I make that balance
about I have to say because I'll get
people piping ups and they're innocent
people the individuals that I ever came
across and dealt with were not innocent
people they were serial criminals they
were sex coaches they were they were
paid the files and we call them Nazis
they were horrible horrible people and
unfortunately what the public and this
year dropped in as a police officer and
see the true
evil that can be inside a human being
you will never understand
um what what's out there what you could
be standing next to a bus stop
um and and my first few years I saw all
kinds of stuff that really changed my
attitude
um you know with sex offenders and uh uh
um you know domestic I'm going domestic
violence back in them days women didn't
really have a support network they never
get a clump from the husband we'd turn
up and they'll tell us she doesn't like
a complaint and then we would do well no
we're not going anywhere right if you
Misses we're working with you so I did
get a clump right that's what happened
well so you turn up to the place you're
in their house oh [__] why should a
woman get a black Iron or bust his nose
from somebody who's pissing and if I've
never had a Friday night out and he
thinks it's not acceptable back in these
days now we didn't have enough
everything else so we would might say
we're going to Nick in for max out one
place anyway get him out the house right
yeah give the woman an opportunity to
have a bit of Brave in space if she
wants a making plank she can we're
taking you out the house one more
another but let's let's say are you Phil
yeah being helpless let's see how you
feel get taking the clunk and there's
nothing you can do about it and would
people like that not complain afterwards
would they not oh very I mean this is
what I'm saying
in them days you wouldn't get that many
complaints and if anyone did try and
pipe up the inspector back in in the day
that they had the sort of power to say
just off wow you know and um and and but
what I'm trying to do is compact many
years of doing I was into a small period
of time wasn't like we was going out
doing this that in vigiland I mean some
people will say oh it's a fug he's a
vigilante maybe I was both of them
things you know legally it was wrong but
morally is a different and some people's
eyes it's different you know
um but these these attitudes were formed
over a period of time for experience
I've seen things and people and
dangerous people very dangerous people
and would you so when you gave the two
types of corruption yeah the examples a
minute ago one is basically personal
gain yeah one is basically for more like
switching the Gap we call it okay
Bridging the gut right evidence yeah
right bridging to get Providence would
you
it sounds like and correct me if I'm
wrong but like
did you see what you were doing as
morally correct like you would never do
something where you'd steal money for
example or would you well we'll get on
to that what I did yeah so I started off
I guess my I guess my question is like
would you see that kind of policing what
you described as old school policing as
a moral way to safeguard the community
rather than a way of taking yeah I mean
Laura into your own hands for your own
benefit yeah I mean it was I mean it's
all right for people to say no I'm I'm
being straight down the line I I don't
care what people think of me I've got to
be honest but I'm sitting here I'm just
going to be trying to I'm an angel with
a dirty face that's why I said okay I'm
not gonna sit here and try and make
myself uh look good because there's
there's not much good in some of the
stuff I've done but morally like you
said in my eyes and that are my
colleagues we were taking people off the
streets like if we like I said to you
the the the the uh prolific burglar he
is at to do Burger he's at two in the
morning right we know what he's up to he
knows what he's up to we're going to get
him off the streets One Way Or Another
We're going to use the words of means
act we're going to lift them for
whatever we can and get him locked up
then we know he's not doing any burgers
at night
and that's what happened it's about
how can I put it so these people that we
were dealing with they were regular on a
regular basis committing crime and every
now again we'd catch them whenever again
we won but we know there was that's
there that's their craft you know if you
speak to him you have old school
criminals they'll tell you the same
thing that's their craft it's the name
of the game
um but back in the back in sort of the
early 90s
um I'm not as I said I'm not saying it
was a sweeping across the board it was
like-minded individuals from certain
PlayStations so I was in a divisional
police station but around us was uh
Sarah [__] and corringham and Tilbury
police stations they was like the
satellite mix
um attached to grow so there's four
PlayStations there yeah now we know
everyone in every near enough so we know
who the grasses were oh the plebs were
and so everyone knew everyone yeah so
you were name in Essex but when you go
to met it's just a number so you might
know that only a few you know you need a
lot of them but this the Knicks are so
big
you're not going to know everyone
and so it's a very tight unit
but when I when I talk about sort of uh
using using unnecessary false uncertain
individuals
um you've got to remember that at the
most sort of uh the best tactical option
a police officer has got is his Gob so
oh I wasn't in my eyes I only I only did
what I did
um because I thought it was right I
never went looking at to bake paper like
coming out of pubs and all that [__] I'm
not interested in that I'd rather ask
you to get in my place card than have a
fight with you because it's safer for
you and it's safer for me so you get to
have good communication skills
you have to be able to talk to people
um in Essex because you could be waiting
10 minutes 15 minutes for backup because
there's not as many of you yeah so if
you come out with an attitude if you
haven't got good communication skills
you could be getting a kicking for 10
minutes
and that's I think the problem when with
the Met because there's so many officers
there there are a lot more offices in
them than anywhere else
people with bad attitudes get in the
mirror knows people bad at a chance
people's side about actually in Essex
but in the Met though I work with people
that start to find an empty room
you know they just couldn't didn't have
the communication skills and a lot of
that came down to lack of confidence in
their physical selves
um I'm a firm believer that a police
officer should be as fit as they can be
not only for the Ramones well-being but
for their families well-being for the
college well-being and for the Public's
well-being because if someone's getting
us the red kicked in down the road and
you're a fat blob by the time you get
there you're going to be killing over
yourself or if you're an orange on a
toothpick you're that skinny and you
can't take care of yourself letting down
anywhere else you're a liability
so I'm a firm believer and if you put
that uniform on you should be fit enough
to do the job yeah because as I said to
you you could be lying I'd rather after
uh defend my actions in a couple of them
be lying on a military slab yeah
that's how I sit
um so I know I was one of the top
self-defense instructors in the Met
um so I sort of tried to try to engage
and say look you know boxing and sort of
stuff like that it's physically fit but
a lot of police officers have never took
a punch
so if you've gone to a violent situation
you think it says police you're
Invincible no you're not no you're not
you know um as I've seen it police
officers too front to get out of course
when it's all going off and people are
getting flung about
because they've not got the confidence
well you say you say there that about
being a instructor and a defense
instruction so we've jumped ahead a
little bit so you did eventually end up
in the Met then didn't you
yeah I mean I mean I think we should
cover the sex cases bit first okay let's
do it so so my and my sort of Entry or I
suppose no no will cause corruption yes
was was as I said I was a willing
participant I wasn't a muppet I wasn't I
I was willing you know what I mean I'm
not going to sit there and say oh I had
to follow along because I'll be bullied
no that's that's not right I felt the
same way as these individuals did these
are officers you know I felt anger and
and um and I remember my first dealing
with a sex case
um
uh pedophile and um it got previous for
a lot of previous offenses against
children this is my first now experience
with one of these types of individuals
and it got caught putting a not giving a
nine-year-old child a note through the
skull fence and it basically said how he
wanted to have sex with her and what he
wanted to physically her to do to him
okay right so you know when I said
Shooters Peter that can the nearest you
come to River was sort of sound like
well this is this is what it was I
couldn't comprehend a man like doing
that you know what I mean let alone the
other stuff he'd done
um and then that was one incident of
this individual come to light
and then another time I was on a night
jury and we got a call to Gray's railway
station that there's a there's a youth
laying on the tracks
so obviously it's a it's a higher grade
incident so we rushed down there I think
it was 14 or 15 this led intoxicated he
was crying he was laying on the side of
the Railway track so he grabbed him up
and he said I just want to die I have it
I just want to die so it's only
youngster really yeah obviously kicking
off you know it was a it was quite
emotional so we got him back to the
police station and um
sort of told us he's under the social
services
so we've got them out and they didn't
tell us anything at first so we let them
go just said all right look he's
obviously got issues whatever anyway he
suddenly become every night he's tearing
up the High Street he's nicking at the
shops so we've lifted him again took him
back to PlayStation again and this time
the social services has someone told us
what the situation was
basically he's dead and a number of
other pedophiles had been convicted of
mode in a Schoolboy
and horrifically abused him before they
killed him and this boy was the dad had
passed him around to all his mates oh
God and he's been horrifically abused
um and and then you realize how horrible
how evil I said how can an individual do
that that's these type of people that
are out there
so as far as I was concerned that's when
I sort of deviated from the script you
know women to be impartial you know a
place without fear of fiber
um but I just couldn't do it
and I remember
seeing
um so I remember seeing this individual
that I'd previously said to you about
the kid with a note yeah I was on foot
patrol in Gray's High Street and I say
this places
and it was night it was like Friday
night where he was hovering about I
thought you think funny don't you mate
it might
and that's when I've been told what did
you say me I said what did you say to me
both you're nicked I'm loving you I just
made it up right called the police fan
down you got a clamp in the back of the
van got into the PlayStation give me
another clamp locked him up for Section
four I can't remember a certain place
something I made up got him off the
street I didn't want him on the streets
and after that every time I see that
individual or another one another sicko
it was a little fella and what his
little thing was he'd go into women's
clothes shops
and he'd go I'm buying a wet dress for
my wife and I just need to try it on
because he's my son said go in and start
masturbating then he'd call the sales
assistant over and actually I opened the
curtains he'd be finishing yeah
um you know and these these types of
ponds that's what they are the pond life
you know people say to me but they
should be protected under the rights No
Ordinary Decent people get protected
yeah you've failed in your duty as an
Ordinary Decent person so now you you're
not subject to protection under their
laws as far as I was concerned about the
college so every time we saw these
people would stop them and turn them
over and abuse them and invariably beat
them up Stitch about them lock them up
that's what we used to do did they know
why you were doing it yeah all the time
all day long so they would they would
eventually become scared of I suppose
being in public this is what I'm coming
on to this is what I'm coming to so what
we we did with these individuals was we
made them every time they came out their
pits they're looking around their
shoulders they're more busy worrying
about us and they were about committing
other offenses that's how we saw it the
more pressure we put on them and they
knew every time they see a police car
they start trembling now you know what
it starts to be a victim of that that's
a that's how we perceived it and like I
said it was when the opportunity arose
it wasn't every time you know we weren't
going out on vigilante which is we're
doing normal placing but these people on
our radar and um and that's as I said
that was just another sort of piece of
my
corruption what happened there you sort
of started to I feel like you started a
story about the the boy on the railway
tracks about his dad was there an end to
that story no we just hate basically I
went sort of after when he came and the
ride off he sort of uh what we would do
with him we'd get calls we'd just go to
the shops and square up just just so not
arrested him just whatever just did we
wouldn't arrest him anymore we can't
look after him and just took him back to
the Social Services whenever we could
but he was messed up you know but again
back in the early 90s it wasn't what
that you know there's not as much care
or sort of in society now individuals
like that's what I'm saying about women
used to get battered and stuff like that
um it was sort of uh
you know there wasn't much care for us
as police officers you know now you've
got uh you know you've got all sort of
paper that can look after and sit you
down and talk to me feeling all the rest
of it back then if you did that you get
the taken out of you well were you like
were you concerned for yourself like
were you worried about the what would
happen if it was found out that you were
doing this stuff I said I want no
because I was with people who I trusted
and we're all doing it together and as I
say even we know what people were doing
and whatever else
um but like I said it wasn't a frequent
like we're doing this every day it was
every other now and again so that's one
of them that's ever word
um you know I was come back to um
um when I dealt with that body that that
person yes because don't forget what I'm
trying to explain to us there's a lot of
different emotions you feel and you get
being in the place
so you know people can sit there I put
that uniform on he's got a good complex
no I was just a normal person that put
just because you put a uniform it
doesn't change I mean it is fantastic
human being you're still the same person
you was but now what you've got to do is
you've got to face all these different
feelings that's coming flying at your
thick and fast like perverts and women
being beaten up and fatal car accidents
and stuff like that it's a lot to take
in when you're a youngster but what do
you think is the difference with you
where because obviously a lot of people
would have become a police man and put
that uniform on and not gone down that
route yeah and that's right I've failed
in my duties as a police officer I'm not
denying that I found I should have
stayed impartial but unfortunately I
wasn't strong enough um and you could
say
my colleagues weren't strong enough
either but I think what you need to
understand is in the 80s and 70s and 80s
that was sort of part of the norm that
sort of policing do you know what I mean
it was like that's how it was and then
it was Stein out gradually so I'll
probably cop the tail end of it and what
we'll come to when I finally did get the
trailer I mean but that story I was
telling about uh my emotions so I went
to I was with my inspector I was driving
him about and um
we've got a call to a suicide at a soap
pad a factory
and um so I went down there and there
was it was imagine a big warehouse and
it's got like a train track going around
it and it and you know like a cold train
those sort of carriages well it had them
on it and there was like a shoot that
came right down to the top of the tip of
the the uh
The Carriage the sort of uh trolley
things and it would show powder in the
thing
anyway so we've gone in now and these
two gentlemen who were working on this
floor were completely messed up they
were crying they were wobbling they'd
see that basically they're coming in
their friend was laying on the floor
with no head
um yeah so they initially thought it'd
committed suicide that you know they
would they were traumatized we couldn't
really get anything out of them I don't
blame them you know this is my I think
this is my first dead body
and I was like oh no don't faint don't
throw up don't fight because I'll get
terrorized because that's that you know
there was no touchy touchy feely feely
it was all you know and um I went in my
inspector and sure enough there was this
body line on the floor with no head
and um blood everywhere and he was
laying fries down
all the machines were Switched Off I'm
looking around where the heads before it
blown his head off or something we
couldn't find our gun
so uh so his whole head was messy yeah
from uh yeah so I figured part of the
bottom jaw was still was still there and
I could see his brain from his brain
sticking out the top I didn't want to
pay too much attention to be honest with
you and um anyway so I said to me right
page you staring guard that that body
and he put in my other colleague
downstairs there's a lot of uh fire exit
stairs they put him on the next flight
then stop anyone from coming up
he moved is he flinched there no I just
it's just weird things I was starting to
get a bit the wind up you know a bit
fine and all of a sudden it went right
started making this like noise myself
I burst through the doors jumped down
the flight of stairs I literally thought
was it was waking up
Squad my colleague and say this site
going on up but you need to come up
because my smart City thing was talking
and uh went up there and he's looking
what are you on about and it was yeah
the radio on didn't they and someone had
called on the radio downstairs and it's
come out on his [__] radio
um oh honestly I thought I was gonna
have a heart attack of course that he
got on the radio then what I've done I
got terrorized absolutely terrorized for
that you know what I mean there wasn't
no oh you're right yeah your feelings it
was like oh
and um and then I started thinking
afterwards because of that because of
that
what happened was they called the scenes
of crime then to take pictures
and uh there was just in them days it
was CID he wasn't civilians it was crd
blocks two ultimates turned up her Titan
pictures and so right now go and find
the head you because I'd hit myself I'm
there one one has to find a head so I
switched on the machine when I'm
climbing about on this
machine another founder
his head was just resting on the top of
the machine with his mouth happened like
one of his eyes had popped out and he
was just staring at me God and um and I
can't I said it's up there I found it I
was trying not to be sick I was like but
it was so horrific it was like it was a
lot of damage you know what I mean it
just didn't look real because it was
horrific
so the soccer boy gets up takes the
pictures and all the rest of it
ambulance have been and gone there's
nothing I can do as I said well I need
to get the head down
because you'll have to get that down I'm
not touching that I wanted me to get up
there and physically get get the head
down I said there's no I'm doing I'm
able to punish me for yeah you know what
I mean and uh anyways I didn't do it in
the end I don't know so what would
happen to him basically we think uh he's
only just come and this is what I
started thinking when I talk about
emotions
I started thinking about when we found
out it just come back up for two week
holiday with his wife been to Jamaica
where we'd been and um so I'd obviously
had a nice time it was gonna I was
thinking oh I started thinking about his
poor wife and that's what got to me then
I'm thinking about the impacts behind
him he's gone there he was left behind
and that's what I was praying don't send
me Rand don't say I can't deal with that
go and speak to his wife I couldn't do
that I hope they let some senior people
there but um but yeah he looks like he's
leaned in the machine for some reason
and it's gone thump
just took the top of his head off but
this is I never did find out I never did
find out I totally still be fun people
oh well I just don't know I never did
find out whether or not he'd done it on
purpose or whether it was an accident
yeah I guess you just move on you don't
get time to to dawdle because the next
job's coming and then something else
happens you know I mean maybe that's a
good thing yeah you know it's just stuck
with me but I moved to different sort of
things don't dwell on it you don't some
people don't I mean I was with
colleagues who had mental illness over
certain things and they they you know
they went completely mad
you know and um they didn't really have
a network back then so that I mean
that's quite an intense introduction to
that job everything you've just given me
there so you started off in Essex in
this smaller place yeah and eventually
you did move into the map didn't you and
and how was that how was it different so
that was a lot different because you
know you know we when I was in Essex I
know all the little bags and they know
me and so you know where to go I've set
it up and you go to their house so
you've got to whatever so you know you
had you had a mutual understanding yeah
so you know I'm saying oh this person's
got to come or whatever else for those
specific reasons but you also needed to
be someone who people would trust and
know where he's straight he's a straight
talk is a straight shooter so we can
rely on him so you know sometimes if I
arrest someone say look just just
something you've got to say we'll go
back to Nick and I'll sort you out quick
if you wanna I'll keep you know down all
night if I have to so you have like
you've got to use your discretion
sometimes when you're in place I used it
a lot more when I was in the Met because
as I said to you I I work with some
fantastic people and I wasn't the best
copper in the world I was what I was was
not a plodder but I I came from morality
family and I was always looking to to to
be uh to be a millionaire
and which I achieved but so the police
wasn't my first love if that makes sense
I was in the job but I wasn't married to
it so whereas you get picked with that
we call them job
and what that means is it's all about
the place place all my friends are
placed everywhere I do it for that place
well no that that's where you go wrong
you've got to have a life outside that
organization
yeah because otherwise it's the them and
US culture
um so I uh
I I went to marylebone
and um I realized quickly as I said to
you about there were people fantastic
places but it was also plums there who
caused trouble for no reason you have to
start finding an empty room like I said
so and you're having a deal trying to
deal with the way I my style of policing
was quite direct and like fair enough
you know if I'd stop a car when it was
four four fellas in it and then what
they'd do is they just Chuck their
weight on the floor straight away well
if there's too much to Let It Go you'd
have to say right one of you just got to
come with us have a little chat and then
just pick the stuff up come out and I'll
meet you otherwise I'm gonna Nick all
four of you so let's just have a bit of
leeway discretion yeah with enough to
Nickel four of you but if you want to be
fine it will just do a lot just take a
lot of you and was that you what would
the official line have been that you
should have done the foreign were were
you allowed to make those you could do
because back then you know cannabis she
was arrestable offense not now it's a
fixed penry or whatever pants is no do
you know what I mean which is fair
enough it's but the way I looked at it
especially if I stopped a youngster in
the street and I'd say I need to have a
bit of weight on them or a couple of
spliffs
I'd rather just say look just Chuck it
on the floor and tread on it and it's
off because why do I need really need to
ruin this kid's future for a couple of
drags just because I want to put a body
on a score sheet because that's what you
had you had people called Faith catchers
police officers said Nick you for
walking on the cracks in a pavement I
wasn't like that I was sort of um I was
applauder yet like I said I'll arrest
you you know I'd arrest people don't get
me wrong but
I thought would I really want to be Nick
for like that no so let's let's try and
have a bit of as I said you're talking
and work it out
and that's how I placed but then there
was other officers like I said would
cause a problem and sometimes you'd
think mate you've put me in a position
now because I'm gonna have to write my
notes to back you up and you're a tosser
um and then what okay it was a good few
years I was at marylebone and then you
know there was I saw alcoholism is
another thing that affects police
officers
um and I remember one officer he was he
was
um there used to be a a um a section s
which was sort of attached to mail
around PlayStation
and there was one officer in there it
was in a bad way and again back then
there wasn't that much sort of help like
there isn't there and they ended up we
got of course from tourists and
someone's been on us from the top of the
building
and when we were up there it was in
Jesus you know we told we didn't do
nothing just took him down and looked
after him but he needed help bad you
know and there wasn't a process to put
it wasn't really no it was just looked
after just
quite getting back in his room and to
tid him up clean him up and they were
like that sort of it was look hard look
enough but not looking after it makes
sense you know plaster on it yeah yeah I
mean it wasn't as I say it was more
it wasn't so touchy touchy feely feeling
that's the bottom line it was you know
if I think in terms of that but it would
still look after you you know if he was
a as you was getting on his service and
stick you in a control and we'll put you
in custody of his rather than panned in
the boat working for a living put your
tuck your eyes to see your last few
years there so he was looked after so
you you would you do anytime when you
met and were you enjoying it at that
point yeah do you know what there's a
story I want to say that I missed that
so I went back in Essex you're talking
about uh sex offenders yeah and um
because it comes back to haunt me in
Maryland okay
so one job was in in Essex we were
driving around we've got cooler man's
been robbed at knife Point been stabbed
in the hand
so we got to enter the go looking for
this this suspect little ginger thing he
was looked like cat weasel caught him
and um it was a horrible little thing
previous for locking a kid in a Cupboard
right in his in his room which which was
a [__] anyway but this was
previously dealt with him anyway we
caught him it's meant we've had six or
seven quid on that he's rubbed off this
man stabbed the man and got the knife
off him and when we went back to his
house to do a Section 8 research
we found loads of women's underwear on
his bed and you understand what he's
done them I don't need some kind of
graphic things so what he'd been doing
to him yeah then we find on the crown
complaints that all the people's women's
washing a big guy missing off their
lines in the local area where this
little lived so I've been going around
Nick in order
and that was the woman in science right
there I'm thinking right he's definitely
wrong on I said to the custody side
because they're back in them days we
could
keep you in custody you didn't have to
bring up the CPS and that made the
decision inside there so it could be you
know you skip all the governor so he
sits in I said don't let him out there's
something not right about this block
he's a weirdo
I said there's something not right about
me saying ah I just bailing myself sarge
don't bail him anyway he end up bailing
him
and um and they never turn up for court
whatever else she's got China you got
charged did you get charged got charged
a thing but it never turned up about
charging about but never turn up for
call I'm there marylebone
and unbeknownst to me it came on the
news I found out this this individual
had gone into the if it was a Cumberland
Hotel as a hotel
um at the back of my other band
PlayStation he's gone in there and raped
a woman yeah
rapes a woman and uh got caught in West
Sussex in a stolen MR2 I think
and that played a marketer had we locked
this thing up that might not have
happened because it literally I now
moved to the met and then this this all
kicked off so would you when you hear
stuff like that would you have blamed
yourself at the time no
I'm PC I can't force someone to do not
the sergeant to try not keep him in
custody you know I'll try my best
because would you feel frustration yeah
I did yeah because I felt in the back of
my head maybe this wouldn't have
happened if we'd have just got him
locked up he might have got three or two
or three years he probably would have
done for robbery and stabbing someone
and whatever else and fifth of the
knickers and all that was that was the
indication that there was that sort of
situation there with the knickers and
the bras told you some form of Debian
plus looking up a kid in a Cupboard you
know the the the the the signs are there
you know and then the robbery and then
and then that's what he's gone and done
is he's going to rap to him
and with the with the
the Essex police force you with with the
kind of old school policing about giving
people like beating people up basically
or or or what did you call it Bridging
the abridging the gap which is yeah
Bridging the Gap would that did that
continue in the map for you yeah it did
to a degree I mean it was um so I'm not
going to tarp officers with the same
rush because I said there was good
officers out there I'm you know I'm not
I'm not a vigilante you know whatever
you think of me I just did what I did
you know I got into this design with the
sex cases I'm not a hero I don't [__] my
hero you know what I did was wrong it
was illegal I understand that like I
said I'm going to go back to them days
and what's social acceptable it wasn't
but it was it was turn a blind eye yeah
the difference is now you're going to
get kind if you do something like that
and rightly so if you put the uniform on
you take the oath if you take Liberties
then you've got to pay the consequences
you know you know if you dish it out
better be prepared to take it as a
police officer you know what the score
is it doesn't matter if you was doing
something for that you thought was the
right reasons if it's not in black and
white then don't do it you know I'm not
advocating
you know office the guy it's not the
it's not that it's not that world
anymore
don't do it again stop it don't worry
not very rarely
um but what I
um I realized as a situ in Essex you're
a name everyone knows you in the Met
you're just a number because there's so
many of you as I said so that idea of of
being able to do things because you
trust everyone trusts you melts into a
different sort of situation it's a
minefield
then you might have a number of people
who are like you or like-minded and you
all stick together Band of Brothers
whatever you want to call it
but there's always one and that happens
to me it coming a bit beyond the back
side
so
um on Friday night Saturday night get a
call to Oxford Circus
um train station Tube Station to British
transport police officers have just been
severely beaten up by four jobs
again they've gone down there to tell
these Lads to go on because they were
terrorizing customers waiting for trains
in there and there to switch them beat
them up pretty bad pretty bad right
cowardly fainted though they weren't
that they didn't know what they were
doing what I mean they were just thugs
aside of course
um I I uh my colleague was driving a van
a sherpa van back and then just a bench
seats in the back you didn't have a cage
like it has any cameras and all that
sort of palava
so we've put one of these scumbags in
the back of the police van
uh and I've got jumps in the back but
unbeknownst to me a female officer from
Holborn police station has got in the
passenger seat of the van
now as I said to you if you're going to
do things you make sure you know who
it's your people surrounding you
well I didn't I didn't know she'd got in
there
so I had a conversation with this with
this individual and I basically said
we're gonna have a straightener and I
took the Cuffs off him can you explain
what a strange because we're gonna have
a fight you know he was big and brave
beating up two police officers and
that's one on one and that's that that's
what I you know that's what I did I
don't profess to be a hard nut
um these stories don't forget I'm
condensing over a long period of time
but these are the stories that stick out
to me what happens if everyone knows
everything I've said to you now if my
colleagues now I'm telling the truth
obviously I'm not going to name them but
you know there's no contention that I'm
lying in any way shape or form I'm being
totally honest down the road I don't
care what people think of me I've done
what I've done and I'm just being honest
and on this particular occasion
um
we had a fight and they ended up getting
knocked out
but what happened is the woman police
officer had heard about something about
straightener seen the Gaza with his
cuffs off and then obviously same same
unconscious so I should Report with it
this this idiot or or
um at a tough tussle with
um got charging for certain place never
mentioned the one-on-one we had I think
it was old school he obviously knew what
the situation was I explained to him why
I didn't so was he happy to do it yeah
he was still Larry yeah he thought he's
gonna beat another one up right so it
was he yeah coming in so we did
um don't worry it could have gone the
wrong way he could have knocked me out
and then we'd have all been in this
so um so yeah that that incident and she
reported me and uh I remember Sergeant
comes because yeah you've got something
coming in a while so what is it you guys
are
WPS in the back of that van I went oh no
so what I did was I wrote my statement
out so I had it written down certainly
Correctional come and see ya and they'll
say yeah
ah just stop before we're going into
let's just have a little chat off the
Record see what we can work out but
they're all marked up yeah never trust
an anti-corruption copper yeah
and uh
don't cut them Orchestra if their life
depended on it at the end of the day and
um so he's come up to he's going oh just
tell us what I said sorry sir I can't
I've that's my that's my witness
statement what I've already wrote out
through my statement because yeah but
what about sinners now what about Sir oh
would you respect I can't remember to
think that's what I could remember all
right it's all right listen he said um
just so you know the individual never
made a complaint and I'm not going to go
and speak to him he said it was the
officer who made the complaint they said
what they're doing their training school
is their teaching officers if they see
something on a here something they don't
like to report it
I've shot damper at the time but that's
how it is life moves on that's if that's
what people are being told it rightly so
if you hear something you see something
you don't like don't report isn't it you
know I can't why should I be someone who
or us as a you know organization are
full of dinosaurs like I was back then
controlling environment you can't
control an environment when it's moving
along and Society is moving
so uh he said to me I know what he did
and I know why he did it he said but you
can't do things like that anymore he was
a Chief Inspector
and to be honestly it was all right he's
the only one that was ever all right and
I understood that and he gave me the
message loud and clear your time is up
right you know what I mean so I thought
I've had enough of this that's me so it
was like an unofficial like you you're
outdated it's time yeah yeah basically
your time's up right it's time's up you
know what I've done he could have made
life worse me could have gone after the
blunt said look we know what's happened
but he didn't he said I'm leaving it I'm
putting it to bed and that was my that
was my warnings you know you know see
you later
I've just thought you know what I've had
enough I'm gonna make a call and get get
out of here and find a nice little
number where I can just just do my own
thing so you were looking for somewhere
else that you could experience the
camaraderie that you had in the police
yeah I'll just go get back to our school
yeah back to old school and you found
that I believe in Royal protection
protection yeah yeah so how do you move
from okay to Royal protection uh from
what I previously told you from what not
what you know so you know that's so that
same situation I mean I
like I said I thought you know what I've
had enough illustrates Michael Cole and
um I remember he said yeah come up
because you earned loads of money hey
guys it'd be sweet but you'll love it up
here it goes no one no one messes around
with us up here
and um so so I I had an interview and
basically if you're bored you get two
office two sergeants and two civilians
and uh what they didn't that was the two
civilians is the day before I'd be
giving all the answers to the questions
I was about to be asked and all the
pictures of all the people all the royal
family that I was going to be asked to
identify
because that's how it was well they just
went we want you to get past the test so
here's the answers yeah that's what
happened I went up the day before for a
look around it's you know yeah right
okay this is how we're gonna do it yeah
nice wait wow and the work the best
thing was well I was asking all these
questions these two civilians were going
oh he knows a lot about robotic all the
roles to me because yeah yeah no we
should be in here he knows everything
only because I've got the [__]
answers to the questions
so yeah I did this past with flying
colors yeah well obviously yeah I think
they thought it was a stalker yeah
and any guilt about that or just no no
why would I feel guilty about getting on
a unit that's at work back in them days
uh because that sounds to an outsider
that sounds like it'd be
very hard to get into right it sounds
like right yeah no there's different
levels I mean what you've got to
understand is I mean it's it's it it
would be hard to get into if you turned
up for a day and we'll have a look at it
and if he was a complete Plum you
weren't getting in if he was saying
about you and you was an ex I sound 90
or cr19 or X kind of terrorism because
that's what happens you get a lot of
people like made disillusion with the
actual place work
and then they have a workout now do on a
Friday night they want a standard
Buckingham Palace they know lots of
money although I roll around on the
floor of a drunk
well we don't know what the answer is
don't we I know so you
I remember when I wish the drive pass
back in Palace and see a couple of role
offices
on the on the gate and we used to go
look at him Nancy's what a boring job
but what they were doing was when I
realized when I went in and I told that
story to some of these fellas I went
yeah what we were doing was looking at
you going look at him no bids working
for a living
[Music]
and they were right they were paying
their mortgages off earlier where's
working with grafting but when you got
when you got in there so
was it was it a case of like you were on
the gates or were you actually with the
Royals like were you meeting Royals all
the time because they're home yeah they
were they were in and out all the time
and as I say my famous stories about
prince Andrew uh the queen uh Prince
Philip and what what were they like as
individuals I remember when I first met
the queen and Prince Philip I didn't
really it didn't really go down too well
because when she comes in if you look at
the front of the palace to the right I
say when she used to come in there's a
garden a big wooden gate to the right of
the palace that's what the entrance the
queen uses only she can use it not
Prince Philip not prince Andrew only the
queen or I think prince Andrew could
because he was the heir to the front
there's a lot of old-fashioned sort of
rules and regulations it's very archaic
but let's say it works you know so
you've got the Duke of edinburgh's door
I think he's got his own door uh the
jookie York's door he's got his own door
into the palace
and um I was on the garden gate one day
and basically when the queen comes the
the Protection Officer people are going
to go he's giving away Secrets again
like they did with last time I spoke so
listen this was 30 years ago yeah you'll
see the car come in and you aren't going
to stop it it's as simple as that or you
can try but you're gonna get shot so
anyway they'll give us a call to say
purple ones well she's dead now I said
there's a romantic purple one's five
minutes
so that means get the garden gate ready
because the queen must not stop that
vehicle as soon as it comes onto the
four cut is going straight through into
the garden it sounds like an easy job
yeah but I [__] it up
right I can't remember I was on the
phone I was over on my mobile I was on
the on the on the Post phone and I was
talking and I could have a load of chat
and then radio and I realized they were
calling me one one nine one nine opened
the gates open the gates
as I've opened the gates the car was set
there
I was like oh I didn't
I've done it just come up for the
streets
oh you know what I mean I'm there
looking after a guy not rolling around
on a Friday night now I'm looking after
a gate
so I'm up in the gate and as I've come
off saluted and the Queen's looking at
me friend and I'm sure Prince Philip
shaking his head at me I can hear him
mutter and so I probably swear words but
in the paper I was looking at me to
fancy again like it looked like I was
going to burst into tears
and as soon as that car stopped his
little fake got out of that kind of
Ransom he said what are you doing what
have you done I'm thinking
yeah the impact you know you're coming
off streets dealing with murders
robberies rapes and I've just been like
open and It Go what's going on well
we're not the old Story the old term
falls from the top downwards it fell on
me really it buried me yeah I wasn't
allowed to go on that post for about two
weeks I I had the governor's running out
the skipper running out what you're done
what you've done all running around like
there's chickens yeah
sorry they wouldn't let me go on that
guy fraud and I realized there's a
different sort of yeah atmosphere in
this mob can you tell us a little bit
about your interactions with prince
Andrew right so
yeah because um the queen
um I'll stay straight away was was a
really lovely lady I've said it before
and I said again
um
she uh she would look after her staff
um as I said before you don't really
talk to the queen she talks to you but
that's just how it is that's a system
that's that's been there for for years
and years but she would interact you
know
other members of the royal family would
just ignore you
um Prince Philip had a Gob on him he
would leave his window open about that
much
at night it was always open I'm a winter
some it was this it never I don't think
it was broke it just never moved and I
remember two Squad he's walking on the
gravel is it like a gravel surround in
the back in the palace there were only
youngsters and they were walking I know
we're kicking the gravel
and he's obviously heard it and he's
opened the windows get off that gravel
and I've realized who it was and I've
well I was like oh no I shrunk down in
my post because I thought oh it's gonna
go for me next so I hid and then when he
gone I'd sit him just go and then he'd
gone he'd done that more he's gone and
called The God room up right Prince
Philip because he had a phone in his
head called a control map if he was
pissed off I would call the Garden Room
and the regimental Sergeant manager
marched that whichever like marched them
straight out they probably marched them
straight into the brick or whatever they
call it
yeah I mean and after that we were told
not to walk on the gravel at night so we
went to Tip Top to get to our security
posts
yeah so we could you know that's
probably where prince Andrew gets his
map from and I've always said and I've
said it in a previous interview if
Prince Philip has stuffed the bar with
cypr and Prince Andrew's Mouse the first
time we told the seventh Corp a lot this
probably wouldn't happen because he was
the most rude obnoxious it was a plum
basically
um and he had no regard for anyone which
he perceived to be below him right we
were all treated much the same servants
his own his own people no one too
frightened to call him out because where
is it going to go and he was I've said
to me you were there why didn't you do
anything about it right so what am I
going to there was a police officer we
can make complaints about it the way he
speaks to people you know if that was on
the streets and he's and he's started
gobbing offline I don't get folded
enough like a piece of paper and put in
the back of a police van but this is
prince Andrew I mean the first time he
told me to [__] off I was like what
Prince Andrew's just what why didn't you
get used to oh I can't remember what I
did I did something he went oh cough if
the barriers wasn't open in time you
know because some security bills and he
used to fly along he used to is to come
at PACE he's to drive his own car
I need to come at PACE we'll catch the
paper boys unaware you know one goals
and um if they're not everything goes
open that door you for phones that was
one of his favorite one of his little
favorite
um words you the phones
um but yeah he was a he was just it was
it was just dislikes I mean we like I
said we're making plays but who's gonna
go to the Queen the the commander no one
who's gonna want to be the face no one
you know people can understand that it's
it's easy to say the armchair experts
you should have done this you should
have what should I have done I did I'll
go and then I'll make more they'll just
say oh tell us to do it's not back to
division that's what happened you'd get
moved you'd get kicked off the unit
um am I right in thinking that you did
did you ever see you say Maxwell I saw
Maxwell and as I thought I said the
number of times she had the run of the
palace you know our remake River was
just let her in and out and all the rest
of it
um
because of the way prince Andrew treated
us you know we would
and I've got a site and now I've a
member of the royal family performed
like I did no one uh guessed we didn't
know who they were when we were we
didn't know they were I mean we're meant
to be there to provide security and
protection so therefore at least Play
Your Part and give us the data elements
of these individuals remind the young
women are all young women but not young
young they were in their 20s to early 20
late 20s or whatever it was and uh
you know well to those individuals
um but if we'd stopped as I previously
said if we if we if we stop one of these
images with individuals
um we would get a mouthful so they'd
approach say I'm here to meet Andrew
yeah and then you'd
presumably you had to get some kind of
radioing through Yeah so basically what
would happen is if it right the Palaces
are working Palace nine to five Monday
to Friday
and then after that after sort of five
o'clock so any official engagements like
people come to see the queen Prince
Philip would be within those sort of
Time Prince Andrew will have a book at
the security post and it would get a
call from the preview purse which is an
office within the palace police officers
there and staff from different offices
for members of the royal family would
ring down with appointments
they would then give us the apartments
on the outside post so we can write them
in our books so we know such as John
Smith's presenting himself he's got an
11 o'clock one with the queen mate yeah
thank you very much ring Up preview
purse yeah bring them up yeah let them
go through right so there was a process
um and even at night uh when the queer
would have private guests uh we'd know
who they were yeah they wouldn't just
turn up and would you well you're not
getting in that our job is to you know
protect the Integrity of the palace and
protect those that live within it
uh therefore those those rubbers are
there for a reason obviously but with
prince Andrew his idea of uh it was his
ass and to be fair he could have he
wanted him we couldn't stop if he wanted
someone in you know that's it as far as
far as his concern or the police are
concerned if he wants guests to come in
and he refuses to give give us their
details what can we do nothing we have
to which wrong it's you know we're
breaching security I think if the queen
knew what was happening she would
probably not you know not be too
impressed but again
there was that fear who's going to go up
against prince Andrew because you'd
probably be looking for another job the
next day you know it wasn't a a kind of
environment where we all you oh you want
to like yeah we'll take that process
through the system there is no system
the system is you've got the back door
yeah so you know all these people don't
make me laugh because they know what
they're talking about you don't know
nothing is you're working that
environment again and in the place
then you don't know how processes work
and this was an archaic system this was
not a system that people would relate to
because we're talking hundreds of years
not just a few years and you know this
is hundreds of years and that's still
same system it's still in place today
but with prince Andrew
um we would get told yeah there's a his
footman would say to us oh uh he's got
our guests coming at six o'clock if you
could just ring up to me and I'll come
down and pick her up all right now we
don't get the names we didn't we give up
asking because we just get abused I'm on
occasion a female comes
um attends attends the palace in front
of the palace and she's able to see
Prince Andrew and he just previously
come in about half an hour before I
think
um try to ring the football we can't get
out of him so now we're in a position
where we've got a guest here for prince
Andrew but we we can't get hold of the
the footman so she said look which
explains her really sorry we just need
to confirm because as you can appreciate
and I think I said in the last interview
you do get people that uh you know uh
are mentally challenged you know I've
got mental issues and they they'll we
get them all the time I'm here at city
queen yeah sure you're not it's a city
queen yeah but people they generally
believe they're invited to whatever
so anyway we said to this young lady
really sorry
um we're gonna have to hold you a minute
while we just try and confirm
um anyway so I'll ring prince Andrew so
she's got a marble and run him and he
can see us out of his window because it
faced on the phone call and he said put
my head off we can hear him put one of
the officers on the phone and he said to
him a friend of mine listen to me you
fat lady asked let my guesty know I'm
going to come down there with what do
you do yeah yeah that's prince Andrew
talking to you like that and he will
come down and then we're going to be in
a rut situation all three of us going to
be Panda debate together
so we'll let her in and that was sort of
after that that was the the way things
were always
um uh and I come back to that point
because in doing that this happened a
few years ago the same thing
officers at Windsor at his lodge in
Windsor he was in Residence stand there
a woman turns up in a Black Cab
she says I meant to say prince Andrew on
his fiancee or something like that the
officers just let us straight in
this why because the same as us because
they know what they'd get so they ended
up letting this I think she was a stalk
rob you know not someone who was
mentally ill into his private Lodge
wandering around until I realized and
managed to detain her
um so you see that happening you're like
I get why that's happened but I I
publicly said that is exactly what has
happened because those officers will get
in in trouble for something that prince
Andrew calls and that and this was only
a few years ago and we've been saying
this from like 20 odd years ago or more
and that's what I'm saying about things
don't change we can say you know this is
wrong but who's going to listen to us
and when you talk about things not
changing I mean one of the big changes
in the Royals recently is the whole
thing with Harry and Megan yeah and as
someone that sort of like was around the
royal family did you have a particular
view on that whole thing yeah well so
before we go on to that is this is a hot
subject and people are trying to stay
the middle of the road because I'm more
worried about my electricity than I'm
about these two do you know I mean but
you said the wrong thing they're on you
like that either side here do you know I
mean the pro Megan
um well all I was going to say all I've
said that is look I think the problem
with Prince Harry is it's it's if he
wants to vent about his about his life
and about family issues he said that's
up to him that's not no one else's
business but I think a paper issue with
the amount of money that is made off the
back of it I think that's that's where
the issue is you know it's obviously
clearly and deeply hurt by events that
have happened in his family and everyone
gets that we'll you know we all have you
know things that go wrong but he's
decided to vent his anger in public
um is that right is that wrong is it for
us to say not really but people are
commenting on the amount of money that's
being made in that situation I think
that's the problem
um and I think that's that's something
that he has to deal with you know
um that's a very reasonable answer yeah
yeah that shouldn't get me too many
I still have some crack trying to say
something I think that's a fair answer
so
the next bit of the next chapter of your
life after Royal protection
and what would I be found saying that
was ultimately this is where it went
down this is where it went wrong yeah I
mean what happened so so I went to Royal
as I said and I started I was trying to
stop market anyway just before I went to
royalty so I've moved I was still into
property and I stopped in the car so I
didn't really have time for that and I
started trading on the stock market
and um I was quite popular on the relief
as I was driving I was driving into
working expensive cars and stuff like
that so people knew I had a bit of money
around me and so you get reputations in
their plans of places don't you
and um
so I started trading in a stock market
and um I started training on Banks and
water companies and stuff like that sort
of safe stocks initially and I put quite
a bit of money because I have money like
they say money makes money
I started making quite a bit of money oh
this is all right and I had time to do
it because I was like the environment I
was in was not not a uh high pressure
environment now I could go and put my
head on the pillar and sleep and not
worry about caught on paperwork and
presence and all that kind of stuff I'm
now in an environment where I'm
protected I'm in that bubble
um and like I said what's on this side
of the thing we worry about not that so
there was a lot of people up there up
there for the for money making reasons
one had a catering from another one was
a Elvis impersonator I mean it was all
kinds of an Eclectic mix of different
sort of individuals you know what I mean
wanted to make a bit of money on the
side over time you could earn 78 000 a
year up there if you wanted
you know what I mean going up to
Scotland Balmoral Holly Road all those
sort of things
attracted over time because the security
level to be a certain level
but I was I I wasn't interested in that
I wasn't interested in overtime because
I wanted my family my kids my wife and
that sort of thing
and uh I started doing a stock market
and then uh a fellow come up it was a
tiny Blair's Protection Officer and he'd
just been tenured out of his role and so
another one who was pissed off from four
I'm just going to do a side Swap and
come over to rolly and sit tight for him
see what goes on tonight I mean he
didn't want to go back on the beat he
was a highly trained skilled bodyguard
and he was in the stock market as well
so we used to share the pink sheets at
the evening standard and long story
short he identified a share one day it
was a recognition software you know like
now when you've gone in and then you
look for a pair of jeans and all of a
sudden you get loads of pop-ups for
James because they've identified that
that whatever it was that sort of a
software recognition of what what
individuals are looking at
and he said to me oh um
because I was with the Prime Minister I
went to a defense research lab and the
fellow was taking over that company is
about to take that company used to run
this he said I reckon there's going to
go right through it because we don't put
loads of money and just put a few well
I'll put loads of money I thought I put
about 40 or 50 Grand in for a penny
share at the time I think it was like 40
or 50 pay
anyway
within two or three weeks when the
announcement came out of this full it
went from 40 40 or 50p to four pound
fifty five pounds wow so I was like this
sitting on New Life a minute so that was
I blew straight for a bit I mean I was a
billionaire
and I then got a half a million pound
credit limit I was with Halifax share
dealing so I was now trading up to a
million pound a month
um on shares I was making sometimes 20
30 grand a week
um you know I bought my wife she my wife
was down to earth she didn't worry about
nice things but I bought a nice things
because that's what I wanted to do
I was driving to work in 80 000 pound
cars I had two AMG Mercedes I had an
executive house you know I was I was you
know I was doing I was smashing it and
um and again people said why didn't you
just leave the place I should have done
because I probably wouldn't have gone
the job back because of the environment
as I said I was it was it was nice to be
in an apartment where everyone's the
same and you can have a laugh and stuff
like that
and it was all going where I was doing
hot gun all over the world spending
thousand zero There and Everywhere and
the true saying is money makes money you
know I was I was making so much money
for Investments through yeah buying and
selling I was doing a lot I said buying
half a million pounds worth of that
stock I'd either keep it a Daymark like
five grand
you know it was it was Madness honestly
so what happened is I got drunk with
money I was ambitious
but then ambition turns agreed
once you start turning it's greedy
that's when things start going pear
shapes because you start to lose your
you know you you yourself and because I
was trading on a screen
it the value of money I didn't register
in my head how much money I should have
just I should have just cashed it all in
and just bought loads of flats or
whatever that's the most sensible thing
to do but I was so
into this I was like trading on the
American markets the Japanese Market I
was all over the shop try it in anyway
uh 2000 2001 it all went wrong and I
lost a lot of money I came out of I
think about 80 000.
took the rug from underneath me
um and by that time
there's an old saying never chase the
loss in the stock market if you get
whacked in the stock market don't start
trying to trade your way out of it just
stay away from it because emotionally
you're done because you're going to be
thinking about that loss while you're
trying to trade and you're going to do
is you're going to start betting more
and trading more
so what I did was I went into spread Ben
which is an even more dangerous form of
gambling it is gambling that's this
Devil's Casino the stock market you are
gambling it doesn't matter what anyone
says and
um I I started I formed a currency club
with other offices
and I was putting loads I was taking 5
10 20 grand off of different offices you
know and um I ended up trading millions
of pounds again
and uh but what I didn't realize it was
and no one else did I was I was I'd lost
it I was burnt out you didn't realize it
yesterday I didn't realize it myself to
start with I was I was done
and I think denial is a you know people
getting themselves in in trouble because
they don't realize when the game's up
when it's time you know when a boxer
carries on fighting and he's he's done
and he's you know I mean he ends up
getting smashed the pieces the same sort
of thing
I went through I started losing my my
morals people say you never reading in
the first place but you know I started
losing
you know I started drinking and and
anyway the pressure of dealing with so
many places I had about 120 coppers
involved me up and down the country
Scotland I was saying it got it went all
Bandy I started uh using police cars to
send money to different police stations
and they come down to my house I'd have
more place cars on my driveway I'd done
a local Nick because I'm just giving
them I'd have about 150 200 Grand on the
floor putting in all in envelopes it was
trying to trying to keep track of all
this giving it to place cars Place
motorbikes special escort group you know
SEO 19 they'd be flying through London
on blues and Toes not going to a job
just delivering my money so you'd be
that you take the money you'd invest it
and if they made it back it started off
initially it started off with making
money we're making money but then as I
said sure I didn't realize was I was
shot to Pieces mentally and I started
losing and then what because I started
losing I was panicking and taking more
money trying to trade my way out of it
I've gone into try to do property I
bought a million pound bonds conversion
which would have done all right but I
started using the money from investors
for properties that they want to invest
in property
and I started using that putting it into
the market so I was lying I started
lying and become you know I was let's
call me a con man a cheat I was all
those things and worse that's what I
turned into and I look back I don't
recognize that person anymore and I just
I'll become someone I didn't you know I
was bullying police officers I was
corrupting police officers I was getting
them to take out fraudulent loans I was
I could ring up I mean a lot of my
problem was because of my reputation so
people trusted me
um and I could ring up someone in
Birmingham and I say transfer 50 Grand
down to Joe blogs and then do it like
that when I pay I didn't want to know
why they just do it you think people
were scared of you too no not scared of
me no no they respected me but what
happened was I started I started
becoming not not with everyone but
certain people are in in the field and
they said look you need to do that you
need to do this you need to do that you
know like Place escorts I mean what's
that all about I remember I I was
involved with someone who's worth 100
million this this idiot and I had to
give him 50 Grand as a return and he was
on my case
so one of his employers that I knew that
was a Connect
he said I'm gonna we need the money so
that's a lot of cash
so I met him in beckton in a a car park
this has all been in court so this ain't
flannel this is this has all been in
court evidence
so I met him in a car park in a
Superstore in uh beckton I was in a my
pied Porsche 911 career and Toronto I
was in a push that died another area
police area car from dagenham turn up
the BMW estate with two police officers
in it and then I went over to the
connect it was in a BMW X5 I gave him
the 50 Grand cash and said right they're
going to follow you all the way into the
Limehouse link just in case you're going
to get robbed and then there's another
police car waiting for any other side to
take you all the way to London which is
what happened
because on my mind I don't trust you you
could tell me to go oh the money's being
stolen well no it's not going to be
stolen because you've got police so you
were at that point using the police
force basically I was no I'm there I'm
there doing that look I'm not doing that
but no one else is seeing it yeah they
almost they're I've corrupted them and
in their head they're thinking it's all
going well it's all going well yeah um
but um I still don't think I'm doing
that I'm I know I'm shot to Pieces but
I'm thinking I'm all good God and I was
like the paper but in my head I was
thinking but I'm going to get out of
this because I'm going to try it there's
going to be a big trade that's going to
come and it's going to go both No One's
Gonna Know I mean even even when I was
in the on my 200 000 pound in one day on
a trade a gold trade I think it was but
then the next hour a day later I lost
200 000 pounds right and when I realized
I should have realized then when I got
the same feeling losing then I did win
and I should have realized
but I didn't I carried on so how much
money do you think you lost I lost I
lost three million pounds as it was
reported of investor money but I lost
about two million money as well so that
five million in total over a period of
how long is it three or four years I
think it was I mean it ended up
recombinating me getting a contract put
on me a contract yeah a contract yeah
like a Hitman yeah I had a Hitman yeah
like give me an awesome morning I'd seen
all the paperwork it was a hitman uh
then you know he was
uh he had the capability to carry out
um the the the car he just put this out
on you uh basically this indiv an
individual that I was connected with
brought in dirty money into The
Syndicate I didn't know I didn't know it
was dirty money at the time but would I
have kid been at this but I was no right
so I'm not going to say oh I would have
took it anyway because I was desperate
anyway this individual is well known
gangster is he's put his contract out of
me
and and I've ended up it's just starting
to buy this time I'm like taking
sleeping tablets I'm drinking I'm off my
head and I've nearly killed the sun
reporter he's turned up at my house I
thought was a hitman but the day before
I'd gone out I'd seen a fella
look my hair something down when I've
gone around the corner he's in the car
with on a phone he's got my details on a
piece of paper
so I've tried to get him out the car and
he sped off and tried to trap me between
a wall nearly killed me
and Anthony corruption come on didn't
make laughing easy for me they come and
said your life's in danger blah blah
blah I didn't trust him anyway and you
know it's another stunt gonna ever got
them but then the following day there's
some report it turns up and I've got him
very long still shot big big chase I've
rammed his car rammed him off the round
and stuck a gun in his head God
so I've ended up going to court I got
off with that because I feared for my
life you know I thought in it man I mean
you armed police then is that way no no
I had a lot I just got a gas gun
if I'd have just gone I would have
killed him anyway but but I uh I mean
just think you think when things can't
get any worse you know I'm thinking it's
a Hitman imagine rolling over and yeah
I'm a sun reporter I mean that's the
last thing yeah if and then anyway
so I went off in the papers and then and
then ultimately I I get locked up for
witness intimidation on police side I
didn't do it if I'd done it I'll tell
you whatever it was years ago they said
that I'd intimidate a place a police
officer um at his house or something
that happened an sc whatever
um but then I've got I don't know I I
had another argument with with someone
who's involved with me who knew what the
score was and they're about to roll over
on me and that's became I started
boiling but I had a reverend didn't
forget anywhere for that but anyway he's
got frightened and he's gone to the
place so I knew I was going to get
locked up then and that's what happened
I got reminded uh I got reminded in the
custody as a police officer serving
police officer I ended up at Pentonville
prison
and I don't know if any views have ever
been you know in prison but and how long
was that for I spent six weeks there
what happened was I I got there and um I
was put in a cell with a gang member
gang member from South London
I didn't tell him I was old bill and um
I'm surprised they do that yeah no it's
some usually well I did that to start
with so basically what happened was I I
stayed under the radar for oh I just
don't say nothing I'm obviously sweet
and because I had a bit about me a bit
of not Swagger but I could you know I
could talk enough X sort of like because
I'm from the East End anyway so it was
survival mode
so I was turning away so anyway go down
for dinner
I'm in the canteen queue like all the
rest of the boys of your army mates and
as I've come up they signed your name
off when you get your food in this case
I
but over front yeah or I'm going to get
a kick this I'm going to get killed here
so I said are you talking to me I'm
witnessing intimidation you you idiot
and it because it wasn't so sure do you
know what I mean I wasn't Tim Anderson
went a lot and I'm just never never
followed through it I was our bill as
well anyway so they locked us up then I
went back to so you went all right calm
down I made a mistake but what he's done
is he's gone back to his cell because
they were the servery people so they
could stay out and claim the servery so
they were still unlocked we were all
locked up about four or five of them
come to my door and slid the newspaper
under the thing with my picture in it oh
[__]
oh no they're going to think I'm a
snitch
I said well we've got well he said oh
let's have a think what can we do so I
said do you know anyone who I said you
know I'll pay him for protection he goes
yeah my cousin's upstairs he runs the
landing upstairs he's got some people up
there we'll go and see him first thing
and unlock and I said just tell me what
his back there I was sort him out some
money just make sure you're watching my
back I said yeah it's done no worries so
that's me thinking right I've got an
angle to survive
and then about seven in the morning or
six in the morning there's four big
screws on I don't know four and more
come to the door I said Paige get your
kit you're going on a roll no I'm not no
they're always no the numbers what is it
very paying uh
um
VP Wings it called again uh vulnerable
person's Wing okay so that's able to pay
the files and the six cases go so now
we're going to take you back to the
beginning of our conversation yeah so
I'm faced with that there I've given
I've told you I'll give it the large one
back there I'm now I'm faced with that I
was never going on that yeah I said to
you when you when you go a call and all
the rest of it and you're standing what
goes around comes around if you're
prepared to dish out at some stage
you're gonna have to take it and this
was my turn
so I just said something I'm not going
on a VP we're going to issue you know
all right I was cocky I mean fair enough
you know I was old bill and I thought it
was funny I said no I'm not I said if
you put me on there he's my witness I'll
stab the first sex guys that come across
and buy fires I said so I'm putting you
on noticed now he's my witness so you'd
rather take your chances yes I said what
you're gonna do it goes well after if
you're saying you're a danger to other
prisoners I said no I'm not a dangerous
to other prisons I'm a danger to sex
cases and Nazis there's a difference
and he said to me and if you're selling
that [__] you're gonna have to go on a
punishment block
right I think it's well that's all right
thanks I'm gonna get locked up on my own
I don't have to watch my back because we
only allowed it half an hour and 25 24
hours or whatever it is I'd rather do
that get on the punishment block
and uh so that's what I did I went down
and got put in a punishments in the
basement and and I used the word hell
and that's being polite
um it is like an absolute dungeon it's
just so archaic and I went in there and
the first thing you do when you're in a
prison so I only want to turn I'm I'm an
old leg I've done a few years but you
clean yourself it will have bodily
fluids everywhere yeah
um and so you clean yourself that's what
I did and then I noticed I was looking
man there's a toilet roll stuck in the
walls of this
all over cracks in the walls and down
the sink I'm gonna follow the been in
here so I took it all out put it in a
bag and cleaned it all up so nice I was
I was asleep
and about two in the morning I've sat
rattling on my noodles
what's that and then I've run across my
face so Champs I put the lights on my
sub was full of cockroaches oh I know
they were they were big as well
anyway I've realized then what the
toilet paper was for I didn't it was to
stop the cockroaches from getting in
right so I had to spend the next day
putting all the toilet paper back
and it was horrendous in there yeah and
they kept coming down the government
because I was a serving police officer
locked up
she kept coming down going oh do you
want to move on to VP Wing yet and I
said no I said just leave me around I'm
fine because obviously it doesn't look
good for for then does it I'm a police
officer and I'm on the Block
if I just got about 10 cockroaches in a
bag and I said look if you don't leave
me alone I'm going to want to see the
iij the independent advisor group you
know like you get a vicar a lawyer and a
couple of other people don't come in oh
you're right no independent outside the
prisons at seven I said I want to go and
save and I'll show more cockroaches I
mean all right you're right stay where
you are so I wrote it out for six weeks
and I got out so I go to court for the
obviously it all goes off with the fraud
yeah I was in denial look I was in
dinner I still wasn't wasn't grasping
the fact that I'd done all these bad
things and I heard all these people
which I had I've done it all and some
lots of friends and colleagues and I'd
you know I've hurt people bad and
and I just wouldn't have it I was angry
so I went not guilty and um they put my
wife in the door she had nothing to do
with it there was more people who had a
lot more to do with my situation my wife
had nothing to do with it
um and um
I know when I was going to court I uh I
had a bottle of sprite but what I was
doing is I was stopping off at Tesco's
and filling up with white wine oh wow so
when I was sitting in court listening to
all these bad things that I'd done I
couldn't I was shocker now I was just
drinking I'm sitting there like I don't
give two stuffs because I'm I'm suzzled
and I did that through the trial and it
was it was uh you know what was the what
was the outcome of the trial oh I got
guilty all day long I was guilty you
know and I'm just sorry that I put all
those people for a trial I should have
just if they'd let my wife go early on
whatever else you know I was wounded and
as the people saying eyes of grass he
said this about now but no I I asked
what I did was I stuck at another
officer gave everything it's been quite
rightly so they've they were hurt they
were wounded
because I was deluded I started having a
go back when I should have just kept my
gob shut and just took it and I didn't
so how long did you get I got a six wow
okay yeah I mean I I mean to be honest
with I probably should have got longer
um but I've got a six and um I was down
before I got that when I was standing
with another officer it was from
Hertfordshire
man he was it was corrupt in the very
term and I said for self
so we got talking and they said oh yeah
anti-corruption I've done it said I'm
gone I'm gone I said what happened he
goes oh I'll send an information to
criminals and I was doing drug rides and
putting half the money in my pocket and
I was I just thought you know what you
wanker I mean I was bad but that's I
want that's that wasn't me you know what
I mean I know what I did was bad enough
but I don't that's not my sort of you
know an awful uh
and uh because yeah what I did was
because I uh I know they're on me I said
right he goes but I still like I went
for a ride they staged this right this
this ride he said they knew they staged
it goes but I still took money
why would you do it because I thought it
just it's effort I'm gonna do it so
anyway and then he realized he said oh
and then I've got parano and I thought
they were they were following me which I
think they obviously were because and I
had a drug dealers that connect for him
to obviously to do his legs was just he
had a number on the cigarette packet of
the drug dealer that was connected to
right and so what I did was I part-time
outside those agents and as I went to go
and I I quickly through the the
cigarette box in the bin
I think it was like discarding the
connection
it goes into at six o'clock the next
morning I've come through my door with a
big red key
how many interviewing and the
anti-corruption bloke's got the secret
box and plunks it on the table so we
found that in a glove box of your car
what you got to say about it oh right
yeah I mean Fight Fire with Fire right
you know what goes around comes around
you know and he was getting the dirty
bastards I think dirty bosses What About
Us
so you so you did am I right anything
you did three years in prison in total
yeah I mean like again you know I'll
come back to you you know you said to me
did I get did I get a slap in jail I was
so lucky I was saying what I say to the
crop police officers out there what
happens to me I'll quickly tell the
story don't think if you get caught that
it's gonna happen to you because you're
the chances you getting a double clamp
are quite High I was so lucky I mean
when I with this with this particular
idiot it was now I have to be my wingman
because with survival mode now this is
this isn't a little Iman situation this
is now buff we're going away for a
stretch so we've got to get get but see
see matey boy it was so it was all big
in the job doing this that and others
now it's starting to register oh no I
haven't got a radio to call for
assistance anymore yeah you're on your
own now mate and we are the lowest at a
low as a police officer in jail you're
there with the sex offenses you're Danny
with the sex offenses the nancies the
grasses you're the same level you're
just as much of a Target now so were you
scared I was so off key I was so like my
feelings were all over the place that I
was emotionally dead to a degree I
didn't have time to be fearful if that
makes sense I wasn't being a hard nut I
didn't feel I was bro no I was just I
was so shook and my head was so messed
up I was in survival mode
but this fella because he he wasn't just
sort of messed up as me but he started
to realize the gravity of the situation
he was in
and I said to him right when we get to
the when we get to the big ass just
follow my lead all right I said I said
just just do what I'll tell you so we go
we get bust off with this John John
fella we go to Wandsworth
and I get everyone off the other the
other people off the bus first just left
the two-hour bill on there
yeah and um so they'll probably get
processed because obviously we're we're
going to be targets
and we go in there's about 20 prison
officers crammed into this custody
office like I don't know like Tom Cruise
is about to rocking I wanted to come and
see the two bank coppers didn't they I
thought was funny
and uh one of them goes to me which one
I use his page or an iron he goes oh I
suppose you're going on the road and I
might went no I'm not and neither is a
oh you're you're [__] cocky why didn't
you I went no but obviously we'll see
how long you lost mate I've been
probably having a bet like I'll say he's
gonna last the days and last two days
whatever yeah I deserved it what can I
say yeah anyway so
we get put on the induction we're gonna
I'll come over it was dinner when we
actually went through to the proper wing
and I said to him right get your
toothbrush get your eyes and break it up
now he goes well so get your minds from
break it I know we ain't got time to
argue about it and get you and then
start carving the bottom of your
toothbrush because you're going to need
that and I said why are you ready get
that kettle on and put that pound of
sugar next to that kettle because if
they're coming through that door mate
I'm making a wedge right now
so basically what you do is you you get
a piece of newspaper and you fold it in
like a long sort of sections like that
you soak it and you fold it enough so
it's like a v-shape and you put it under
your bed and let it dry because then it
becomes rock hard and it's a wedge
so what you do is you put the wedge in
the door just so there's only that much
if someone's trying to come through your
door I can only get sort of that much
right and while they're doing that
trying to force the dog you've put the
sugar in the in the cat when you've just
gone buff Jesus it's called jugging on
night palming yeah no that's unfortunate
that's that's it now you know there's no
more rocking about in a place called
being a big man
and doing whatever this is this is the
gravity of the situation if this is real
life
um and uh so he's he's there he's now
thinking he's starting to wobble this
fella so I've gone through and as we go
I remember so we come at the induction
Wheels I'm walking through with all my
crap they're all on the land there's
going you pig you pig you're dead you're
dead starting the others we're gonna get
you and I'm walking through thinking oh
no
in behind me he's they didn't even know
it was old bill they just knew up
because I was in the papers I was on the
Telly yeah so I was I was the Target
anyway we're born in a cell and I said
same road ticket get all this stuff
right I think it was there and I said
get the kill already get this and you
can see the fear in it and he's a big
lamp he wasn't like a little worked away
he was a big lump
but you could see him shriveling like a
sink dying in front of me and then we
had to go and get our food another
canteen situation so we went out
and um ghost in the car and saying
there's loads of people but but everyone
knows I'm our building it's not like I'm
style out and pretend I wasn't
and as we're going through getting our
slop this one fella slots on my plate
and goes ah ain't like that in the
police can't say is it mate I thought it
was fun I said would you say to me what
do you do again do I fold like a deck of
cards I'll just take my phone like a
little wimp and walk out or do I find it
out because if I get a kick in I get a
kicking but if I don't I'm going to get
a double kicking so you're in a position
where you know whichever way you're
gonna go so I just sit here would you
say I said come around let's let's go
you know and you can hear a pin drop and
what happened was the screw it was
behind the server he walked out
they walked out and left me
I thought all right anyway the bloke
said to me all right calm down man I've
only went calm down all right it's only
a [__] joke I like the black behind
the server so we went back to her so it
was about to have a heart attack now
this Plum and he's going oh no we're
dead so long story short we uh we got on
the yard it goes to come around the shop
yeah
respect for that he goes I was only
joking mate what I didn't realize I was
he was in with about five others for
armed robberies they were doing a 15 to
20 stretch that could have just killed
me um but um we're not on yard same
thing Amazon boot will come over to me
I've got the side soon just woke off
he'd already gone he'd lost his bottle
you know poor old John who blessedly
couldn't patch his white wet paper bag
stood by me
so when I got back to the sofa I'm gonna
have to come away from him now because
he's just liability so I said to him I'm
going to move cells he goes I'll watch
ya
yeah no no he's so I moved and he lasted
a day and went on the roll right but I
got the Kudos because I found out it was
our bill and that's what saved me this
is my point I'm making that's why I was
lucky because I did that I got all the
codes people coming up to shake your
mind saying do you know what respect for
you because you didn't go on the numbers
foreign so I at that point I managed to
I managed to get myself back and then
start looking at the situation and then
start thinking what you did wrong and
what you think is you you're in jail now
all you got is your press-ups in your in
your thoughts so you've got and I
started realizing actually I did do all
these things actually I'm a scumbag
and if you you can never get if you do
something wrong you're never going to
get past it unless you face it face up
to it you know what I mean if I'd had
the guts about the guts
when I realized it was gone wrong and
face up to they'd go wrong and been
honest do you know what I mean but I
didn't have the guts I didn't have the
guts to face my fears at the time and my
worst fears and and stop what was
happening so a lot more people got hurt
when I was in jail and I started
realizing I realized our chances in life
that I just blew but I was surrendered
by people who never had a chance in life
do you know what I mean and and after
I've took the Mickey
you know did it change how you felt
about some of the criminals you were
coming across yeah that's what I'm
saying some of these people are born
into a criminal life some of them have
never had the chance to get out they
revert to type every time they come out
of jail because they've got no support
system now I had all the chances in the
world and I bloated a lot you know and
that's when you start realizing you're
looking deep into yourself and think you
know what
when you get out just be honest with
yourself and others and just tell it
please our offenders tell it straight
never bother never get yourself in a
situation like that you know when I
started what I did was because I was our
bill I was always going to be a target
for the three years I spent in China
so I started thinking right you've got
to make yourself from a liability into
an asset how did you do that well how I
did it was I was helping people with
illegal paperwork so to come up to me
and the door knocking down so I've got
this letter for my slizzer I don't
really understand it coming I'll read it
for another to explain to you and stuff
like that so I was using my knowledge of
the law to help people and then
obviously that builds some sort of
friendship stroke lower in the game with
helping people to read them right and um
I ended up working as a um doing rockles
for people so they get the home loose
anyone knows it's been a judge the most
important thing is you obviously you can
say but your home visits and your phone
credit so I did I I sort of did things
to help other prisoners
and that got me you know uh respect and
and it stopped me from getting assaulted
in prison you know I become accepted as
they're my people now I'm a fellow in
there I'm not oh no I'm what these we're
all together and that's how we were you
know and I'm you know I got home I got
on well and I survived but that gave me
the the sort of understanding I was in
prison where people have been abused and
obviously there's a couple of people had
said to me I've you know I've gone down
my head's gone and I was abused by my
dad and all the rest of it and I've
ended up in a life you know what I mean
you just start thinking oh
you can understand these people I've
never read a decent a half decent chance
in life I saw what I want just a little
chance you can see talent in some of
these people would have some fantastic
artists in there you know this boy I
said had been abused by his by his dad
it was a fantastic artist he did a mural
a Chelsea mirror on his in his in his
room accordingly and no Governor came
around and made him paint over it and I
thought why not why don't you just put
some posters up when you come around and
then take it down again do you know I
mean it was mentally stimulating for him
and you know you
mental health is another thing in prison
you get a lot of individuals that are
mentally ill and they don't get the help
they need it's interesting because
a lot of the people we talked to say
that go into prison as prisoners say
prison doesn't help them it just
perpetuates a problem it's interesting
to hear from someone that went into
prison as a policeman that it doesn't
seem like it showed you when you like
what do you do now since leaving
um I worked for a major I won't say what
it is but I work for a major company and
I you know I've worked for a friend's
private security company
listen every time I wake up there's
still a bit of pill to swallow what
what's happening to me and what I've
done to people you know I mean it'll
never go away that's a cross I'm gonna
have to bear for the rest of my life and
I understand that
but everyone is you know as far as I'm
concerned the reason I talked about the
prisoners is that when you're a police
officer you've got a jail you're
stripped of everything your job your
family your dignity everything you've
got one as far as I'm concerned and I've
said it in a previous interview you've
got one chance in life one one sort of
uh Bean spray to grow back get grow your
responsibility back and let's don't go
on the sex offenders Wing you've got
you've done what you've done but now
you've got you've got to go on Main
population if you get a clump if you get
leveled out you just have to go to
yourself smash it up or bang a screw it
and get put on the Block
do not go on the sex offenders Wing
whatever you do because that's it you're
done that's our that's how I see it all
right and if you can do that if you can
if you can ride prison at then you've
done something because that's the only
thing you can do in prison obviously
I'll try to help her but that to me was
very important because I've got children
how can I go on a visit and look at my
children when I'm banged up with a sex
case no no and one thing the final thing
I want to ask you Paul is you've
basically had a very interesting life
and you've been through a lot of
different kind of chapters and you've
got a lot of stories like when you look
back over your life what's something you
think you've learned like what's
something you take away from Ollie I
have learned no matter what trouble you
are in yeah
no matter how life
you know no matter what you do in life
just always be honest with yourself
and be honest with people around you
because if you're if you're not honest
with yourself you can't move on you
can't move on in life because you're
still lying to yourself you know so if
you've done something wrong stand up and
be counted yeah don't don't boil out
don't don't try and lie your way out of
it just you'll get more credit more
respects and you'll probably cause less
damage and whatever scenario you're in
if you just be honest with yourself it's
like there's police officers out there
will know them scumbags cousins and uh
uh the other idiot what's his name the
the the one who uh anyway you know these
kind of people unfortunately are in the
job I'll give the job a bad name I
understand I've disrespected the uniform
and all the rest of it but but there are
individuals like this in the job and
there are other offices in the job that
are susceptible to corruption if they've
got a problem they need to speak about
it because the job's bad enough as it is
every year the police service or police
forces I like to call it has a tooth
taken out of its Gob every year and in
the end it's just going to be a
toothless line it's not going to be
effective in any way shape or form so if
his office is out now
uh you know I've got problems I need to
wear them I need to speak to someone I
don't necessarily have to go to
I think you know but they need to just
get it out there because if we can get
people to admit their mistakes and admit
you know there's they've got a problem
we might be able to you know claw
something back in society as a whole you
know just be honest you know it might be
the worst thing you could do in terms of
what you're thinking but you know what
it's better than going down the road I
did
because trust me that just leads to bad
places
it's amazing amazing to hear your story
you know you tell it brilliantly uh
thank you so much that's fine thanks for
having me yeah we managed to interrupt
the drug Supply in Northampton for a
full two hours so seven months of work
nine months 96 people arrested